and my own um
uh new year's resolutions in general i
have been working a lot on robots but i
haven't released anything yet
and uh this is for fun this is not for
the startup and the business side of
things this is just i love robots i love
legged robots and i love exploring the
uh problem human robot interaction both
in research and there's almost like
philosophical art
you know in movement there's something
that robots make us feel
and um
i want to understand that i want to
explore it together with people by
shooting a bunch of videos with robots
having robots hang out with me in in
austin in public
walking around with them uh inspire
people if people are scared to sort of
uh use that fragility to try to
understand where's the fear and try to
educate people grounded in that so i
definitely want to build a bunch of
robots
uh do a bunch of difficult interviews
they're coming up
you know i uh i do see myself as an
idiot i i i do see myself as somebody
who
um
relative to
how little i know
any anything that i do know even things
i spent
several years on just feel so minuscule
so i i think i just lead with humility
in these conversations
uh which i think can get me in trouble
but i would i would like to err on the
side of humility and love but at the
same time
there's going to be a lot of people that
criticize me
often rightfully so
and i have to walk race to that fire not
not not let the ego flare up
to where you start to pay uh we start to
be defensive and all those kinds of
things
instead sort of calmly take the
criticism learn from a girl from it and
i've already had a few in the space of
uh coronavirus a few difficult
conversations and i'll have several more
there's some other very difficult
conversations coming up some of them in
russian
so i've been also practicing russian
i'll take
if travel allows i will take a trip to
russia for maybe two or three months
take a take a journey of sorts to um
to explore the language the people the
struggles
the history
the the future
the powerful and the brilliant from the
science and the technology world
to the geopolitical world and
also khabib
he's definitely going to be on the
podcast
but not until i wrestle him
by the way i love wrestling and there's
going to be a bunch of wrestling videos
uh coming out
uh i mean i just i love khabib so um i
love the the the dagestanis
uh uh
but vaisar said is definitely somebody i
wanna talk to in russian one of the
greatest lessers if not the greatest
wrestlers of all time
alexander corellin
so that's a whole that's another part of
my life that i just keep to the side i
just i'm inspired by sport you know i'm
a scientist first but
sport challenges the body
to me science and philosophy challenges
the mind and i love doing both and they
both
are a source of humility i'm gonna i'm
still at mit
uh i will teach
i will give a bunch of lectures that
i'll teach
uh courses there
in 2022.
i really refuse to teach remotely so
there's i'll speak about this later
there's been a few challenges because of
omicron so
i may i may release a few lectures um
on video but unfortunately given how
many people signed up to the mit
lectures
it's just an insane number of people and
mit is very nervous about what's going
to happen
they might be closing their doors
harvard and stanford is going remote and
given that situation i think i would
love to
sort of uh hug people with open arms
and meet them and not be so concerned
about
masks and all those kinds of things like
i would love to give the lecture when we
open back up fully and publishing papers
i want to
uh i continue doing research at mit i
have so many incredible colleagues there
so many friends so many people that
inspire me i still love mit i still love
boston most of the time i uh currently
though uh spend
in austin
um
like i said uh challenged myself
physically mentally we've been talking
with david a lot he's dealing with some
injuries
i was dealing with some injuries but uh
we're getting close to 100 and we're
going to do something insane together
physically that was a precondition i
would say for a podcast i don't want to
just talk to david goggins on a podcast
you gotta do something uh crazy together
first and then do a podcast survive or
die trying
uh
try okay let's see have fun like what
i'm doing here i did a podcast with tim
dillon the great the powerful one of the
greatest
living comedians tim dillon that's part
of having fun
and um doing this is part of having fun
if you guys have questions about the tim
dillon conversation i'm happy to answer
he's just so he's so awesome and uh
he's he's yet another way i humble
myself because he makes fun of me and i
deserve all of it
and like elon said try to be useful to
others
i think um i really don't care about
personal career success about
any kind of quote-unquote success
financial or otherwise
i i think about
how can i build stuff how can i do
things that help others
it's just one it's just fun and i
think it also directs your mind in the
proper direction
and in the end love add a bit of love to
the world
that's the uh help others
you know i'm a big fan of helping people
move i like lifting heavy things
but in the end the way i want to help
others is just by adding
uh
love to their life in whatever way i can
alright that's it for new year's
resolutions i can say a lot more but let
me just
answer a few questions
you